the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I was trying to look at your face and
say whether you all hate me or not and
there is a say I said I was going to
send the email yesterday and say there's
a time for your evaluation and then I
realized if I send to you yesterday I
probably gather the worst evaluation
right so I just wanted to remind you I'm
getting this in the email you need to do
the evaluation and sometimes I was the
other day I was telling my wife I said
that because we always listen to this
say Car Talk I don't know how many of
it's a very interesting radio talk right
so so the Oh at the end they always say
we squander an hour with me and I say
you squander semester with me hopefully
okay so we have three more lectures and
this is not going to be review of the
posture we're going to continue pushing
and say how much we can stuff there what
we talked in the last lecture the say we
focus on the PN Junction and then from
PN Junction solar cell in fact is a very
light Rory just to see you get a carer
generation by photons which goes the
opposite to the forward bias and then
say we mentioned the shockley-queisser
limit where the the decay is that the
shockley-queisser in fact I just had a
program manager call for two hours in
the morning the pv project that we have
and the so the shockley-queisser is
assuming there's no other recombination
other than really the recombination and
under for photons immediate say when the
electron holes not at equilibrium the
there's a difference in the Fermi level
of the electrons and holes and photonic
media that has like they have a chemical
potential right that chemical potential
is the difference of the quasi Fermi
levels so I was presenting some of the
understanding I had at the end of the
last lecture say this is a very
interesting thinking from the entropy
perspective and so with that we pretty
much finished in terms of what I want to
do a parallel treatment right if you
think about we talked about molecules we
talked about electrons we talked about
photons we talked about the photons and
all of them we use we can treat them
more or less parallel because they are
dilute particles and they have wave Cara
sticks and then have say they the way
that we've been dealing with this is we
talked about the energy level that's
they give to the wave ledger the
quantization of energy due to wave
nature of those matters and then we see
eventually so at a single interface or
motor interface you have in the ferns
you have reflashing and that's
mathematically if you approximately
interface at zero sickness you know that
is always smaller than the wavelengths
right so this is a what a chapter five
was about and from there you you could
calculate transmission so those those
were a description under the wave
picture then we move on to say really
the transition from that wave if the
wave the coherence is lost I don't need
to consider the phase information of
those waves I just need to consider
trajectory of those waves and that's a
say where
is completely trading at the particle
right so if you think about quantum
mechanics or what Einstein say
introduced is the granularity of waves
of photons photons electromagnetic wave
about granular waves so it's a particle
and wave duality and the way that we've
been treating is okay we first retreat
us as a wave propagation and then
eventually we completely exactly the way
we we treat them as a particle we don't
carry their face anymore right so so
there this is from the transport of a
perspective and then we went to the
boards my equation and using boards my
equation we derived hopefully you've
seen that all the diffusion equations or
drift diffusion equations in bulk
materials and then when you have say
boundaries where the boundary creates
some scattering of those particles just
like when you go play say pool and they
your particle or your ball hits the
boundary get reflection rate could be
the sum for most of those transfer turns
out is diffused reflashing
that create additional impedance for the
carrier flow so and then say the chapter
8 was trying to wrap the idea that as a
microscopically when you think about
energy conversion is really the
transformation of one type of energy
carrier energy into another type of
energy okay so that's the interaction
they scattered the absorption the
excitation of energy carrier but at the
same time you have the loss you have the
transport so so you want to design a
good heat engine right your
thermodynamics has to be right
there is a that scattering we have
energy conservation we have momentum
conservation you can think that the
thermodynamics has to be right
and then your transport has to be right
right that's they I say that's the
left-hand side of the board
and I warn you that I say I couldn't do
liquid right so if I think about
electron fallen fold handles our waves
periodic boundary condition and
eigenmode and so with that the dilute
particle approximation is valid and to
deal with so the next we're going to
talk about liquids and I was spend of
only very little time on the transport
in bulk liquids and in fact I say I
think I when I look at the literature I
think if we don't really even understand
well transport in bulk liquids and it
becomes much harder because the liquid
as well as a Martha's material you go to
a Moffitt sitcom right you lose that
periodicity right Christos is an idea
because when you see give a structure
you only have one arrangement perfect
crystal purity right but when you see
amethyst where the atom can be anywhere
you've got zillions of arrangement so
that makes the picture much harder and
the liquid that's oh so liquid and in
fact the difference between amorphous
material and liquid is very small and if
you think about glass right you would
typically think this as a solid but the
glass if you look at say people doing
starting this say glassy phase and they
have real logical properties okay they
could change alright and so so for what
we are first to give a very brief record
out for the bulk what I saw say bulk
properties and how people try to treat
it and then quickly this Fiat Irwin to
computerized see computer simulations
and then I'll discuss more on the
interfaces right in fact that's a
probably most interesting if you deal
with transport
or relate to liquid right see how the
liquid interact with solid at the
interface and they say including the
electric guitar layers and the solid saw
the interaction we have a see the same
interfaces so that's chapter line and
and we're talking about liquids and the
interfaces and I mentioned the say they
if you look after the for liquid say
what are the historic approaches people
trying to deal with liquid right say one
of one approach is trying to modify the
boards my equation right ports my
equation is a say at I loop hard core
right so when you have a more
concentrated high-pressure gas for
example the particle is a lot longer for
dilute so you have the approach to
modify boards my equation right and our
briefly mention to particle distribution
distribution function and corresponding
and Sons coke equation and then the
other approach is really starting with
Einstein is the Brownian motion
and that you actually develop the into
the linear response theory so those were
they see some of the directions and you
actually this one didn't pan out where
it's not very fruitful ports my equation
Prime modified and so most of this
studies now is the based on computer
simulation and linear response theory so
let's really give a very brief picture
of a bulk liquids right and one of the
variable form of the function we use
often to characterize liquid is the
radial distribution function which
actually can be measured using tools
like a neutron scattering tool in the
definition is okay I have so this is
trying to measure what's the order of
the atoms I'll say if I take any of the
atom at the center how the surrounding
atoms are distributed around this atom
right
and so the radio distribution function
is 4 pi this is the see the really 4 PI
R squared ER is gives you the volume
around the R and this n is the average
density of the atoms
and this is the radio distribution so
basically if you look at the in this
radius R from the atom look at and the
thickness of dr right so how many more I
say atoms I have in this small shell of
volume so this is the definition for the
radio distribution functions the number
of atoms in our and our right and if you
think about the difference you can
liquid and gas and the crystals
typically the radial distribution
function so you know crystal if I look
at an atom this is Center the next atom
is some distance away right
the next layer and then the next layer
it's a pure art right so you continue
that's the crystal pure like a Richmond
and if you look harder the so if this is
a G R & R right and if you look at a gas
and the gas is a pretty much like a
uniform distribution and so there's no
really no structure in the distribution
function and then you look at a liquid
liquid is to say if I take an atom you
me the surrounding the air say because
of the mutual influence of the atoms so
there is a little bit of structure and
the way for me there's no correlation
because the atom atoms are moving pretty
randomly so the way I can
the typical distribution function of
this is a dying of after
feel layers of atoms surrounding this
vessel any of this specific yet
okay so what's they use if you do the
use the distribution function right say
the video distribution function for
example I can calculate if I know the
potential interaction between two atoms
so if I know the potential interaction
between two atoms then I can calculate
using the radio distribution function
what's the total potential energy in
this system is 0 to infinite integration
4 PI R square and this is a potential
interaction between two atoms and an gr
dr okay right and if you go back to the
thermodynamics right in chapter 4 we
consider say different partition
function microcanonical system canonical
system grand canonical system right if
you write down the potential energy and
you have kinetic energy you have
potential energy you can actually write
down the distribution functions and from
distribution function you can calculate
the corresponding thermodynamic
potential like a you know canonical
system it's the Fred from free energy
there and in microcanonical is entropy
so once you have this thermodynamic
functions you can say derive all these
thermodynamic property of the system
like the equation of States right so one
one interesting case was the equation of
States so if you do for example if you
see one of ours this is the famous
wonder wash
potential right if we take a van der
Waals potential Phi are the small Phi R
is for epsilon and Sigma or our curves
power minus Sigma over our sixth power
one was potential and then let's suppose
I have this is sort of the radio
distribution function as a step function
right the radio distribution is step is
zero so it's basically here I'm drawing
this way but what I say this step is
just here this is my D so within zero to
D this distribution function is zero so
this is R less than D right you can have
atoms to get a close then D because
that's the territory of this specific
app and when R is larger than what then
D they say this is a 1 so we lost the
structure completely once this is
getting out of this region right so if
you take this two functions you plug in
and what you find out is your Phi n is
this the total potential of the system
is a and square over V the volume and
and using this potential energy in
kinetic energy you go reconstruct the
partition function and from partition
function you get an equation of states
and the equation of state
equation of states you have is a P
equals n KBT and we must be n minus a n
square over a square and the P is the
volume of an individual molecule one
molecule so this is the equation states
that slightly differ from the ideal gas
law PV equals say ideal gas as a PV
equals NRT right and this is the one the
worst equation of states right one
divorce he come from the wonders
potential and the when the VARs equation
of state and they has very important say
historical importance and in fact I say
if you go to check I probably the Nobel
Prize one the first one in physics was
in I think it's the x-ray and the first
one in chemistry probably was one of our
scrutiny by the VARs okay and why
because if you look at the ideal gas law
is a pv p x way equals n RT right and
but the van der Waals equation of state
is actually giving you the liquid okay
so we proud of the equation of states so
this is the for the van der Vaart gasps
it looks like this
one verse equation stays and it turns
out when you take a horizontal line this
error you could this error that's where
the horizontal line should be and this
is the liquid this is the gas and the
in-between so if you for different
temperature you plot it in butane you
have the vapor dome right so you look
high today steep carry sticks you have
in this region you have mixture of
liquid and steam right and this is the
steam region liquid region and turns out
this one you can in between let's say
this is a B say D and B does P to say
this region is impossible and in this
region you don't have a homogeneous
state you decompose so you've got a
mixture you got not one face you get say
water and steam and in this is the SAP
cool you can potentially have superheat
and in between be say somebody lab maker
is absolutely our stable sagadam say
mixtures and of course normally will
always get those mixtures I say in the
hole from A to D region right so the
importance of the one diversity equation
it really gives you courage sticks
powerful from liquid to the vapor phase
historically very important
so that's the thermodynamics part and
from the canonicus part so that's a
transport right so if you think about
the boards my equation and the
assumption we have in the Boltzmann
equation is the molecular kills right
the distribution function at the end
that we say we can use a one partner in
the system the part one particle
distribution function to represent the
distribution of all particles so if I
write down a two particle distribution
function so I time T one partner has a
position and momentum RP and second
particle has a position and momentum are
two P two that's the tube hardware
distribution right and the Boltzmann
distribution say equation is based on
the molecular chaos assumption means
this is independent of each other is the
T are P and times T are - P - right
that's a molecular chaos assumption and
because of this the Empire just a
product of and said of the all those
distribution function to the nth power
and the correction so at the beginning
there were effort on tier 60s okay
people trying to do correction to this
molecular chaos assumption and one of
this is due to an Scott and I'll talk
assume pretty much like a house fear and
T are P and R two
p2e course f t RP f t our tool p2 but
say there is a function here at a
function to prevent for example the two
molecules or two atoms occupy the same
location at the same time right so you
can use that Haase fear so here is the
function represented the distance of the
two molecules and with this colorful
part of distribution function you go
back to the derivation you start with
the Salewa equation and when you
simplify to 2 particle and you look at
your scattering term we derived set of
equations for the for f as well as for G
so this are they so they're what I want
to say I didn't write in fact I didn't
even write in the book it's very
complicated equations but say they were
effort and in fact there are some
solutions to the unscoped solution
equation but say it was found that the
unspoken question
you can't you still you can do a little
bit denser liquid fluids not liquid you
still liquid is very dense and you can
do denser gas but say the renji cannot
be extended very far so because the
equation gets very complicated at this
wrote all for extending the board's my
equation was not successful pretty much
abandoned abandoned after 1960s so the
other direction came from Einstein and I
Stan did a Brownian motion
and that was his PhD thesis right he
wrote this soon was there at a patent
office and they popped all these papers
in 1905 the relativity say photoelectric
effect and the Brownian motion and so
this were white year publications so at
the time he didn't even know there were
Bromley experiment but he know a few
facts and he know that if you have say
so what his purpose was trying to
determine what's the size of Markel's
okay and and he know that when you have
so he was doing more key dunking right
thinking experiment say okay if you have
particles right big Marco's you know
solving right you put the milk in water
and one thing he know was there is ideal
gas law tie for those solute molecules
in the solvent and this is the osmotic
pressure
he knew osmotic pressure and so the
osmotic pressure P is the same as ideal
gas and RT a is the seed number density
of those molecules in the say the solar
marker in the solvent so that's one
thing and the second thing he knew was
fluid mechanics okay and I said now that
when you have a partner right and then
you flew
you have of course this is a very small
part of your and that the stocks track
when a particle moves in the liquid
there's a drag flow and try to drag it
effect right so the drag force does
anybody remember the drag force okay 6
PI mu D well SDR okay I have three PI mu
right so it should be R right okay our
hands velocity stocks formula and he
used this to construct the what's the
diffusion mass flux okay so the so you
can do this but I say okay I have
osmotic pressure if I have a
concentration gradient I have pressure
gradient right so n is the concentration
so if I look at the if you let's say
there is a in the X direction
there's concentration gradient you take
a control volume and you do your
pressure so P X must P X plus DX right
and I should I say this pressure at the
steady state should balance the drag
force on the particle in the in they say
they do to the osmotic pressure the
particles are moving and they say the
resistance on this particle is due to
the Stokes flow drag force so what do
you have here is time so let's say here
this is the pressure times the cross
section let's say here is your cross
section were considering
and minus three PI mu D I don't use R
and you times the Lambor of Parker in
this volume that gives me steady-state
right pressure driven force and they say
resistance due to the flow and if you
write into differential form
what do you have because let's say say x
even sure the DX gives me volume give a
give a DND V gives me another n so I
will have what you get all of this is n
times u equals mass one-third 3 PI D mu
DP DX and DV DX when you say converting
into using the icy osmotic pressure
relation we have a KBT and three PI D mu
and DN DX so this is the flux right if
you look at this number density times
velocity gives you the flux meter square
the number of particles per meter
squared right
so the what we have here is essentially
if you think about the ficks law right
this is your J flux equals mass D a DN
DX that's your diffusivity and say here
the diffusivity is related to
the viscosity diameter right so so from
here you can say the diffusivity is a
KBT and the three pi D mu so from here I
stand say you can do a experiment you
drop milk you measure diffusivity time
it and you can reasonably say it right
you know the viscosity this is viscosity
of the liquid right you know that you
know that you you know what's the
diameter of the molecule so it's very
simple right and so that's why this is
they call the Einstein relation you
recall in when we talked about
semiconductors the semi condor has a
diffusivity and the mobility has a
relation and here is diffusivity
viscosity viscosity is also so in the
term mobility is like a humorous
mobility right and this is a diffusion
its diffusion process right so diffusion
is due to fluctuation
viscosity is sort of friction
dissipation right so this is a one
example of the more generalized say
fluctuation dissipation theorem here we
have fluctuation here we have
dissipation right okay so that was a I
stand treatment and in fact the Einstein
later on solved the other way so if you
do nanofluids you go to read the
Einstein paper he actually saw say he
this is one way to do this and he said
okay you can also add a latter part of
Buddhism in the code nanoparticles
molecules and you measure viscosity
increase so what's the risk
the increase to the base fluid the
viscosity and from there he had another
way to do the same problem so for that
problem he actually has to solve really
he you go to say he actress table the
viscosity flow problem around particles
so you you you can see his a fluid
mechanician we didn't go to the other
research fluid mechanics okay so that
was the starting point there was a very
small book on the Einstein work in this
area on the Brownian motion and very
cheap ten dollars you can go to you
should go to get take a look at it and
so from here there was a say the
generalization so I still have the say
the general general the next
generalization is due to lunge even than
G main fishing and on geo equation is a
stochastic equation just say okay is F
equals MA and but say the driving force
for is due to random thermal fluctuation
so if you write the day if you have was
a party girl in the liquid and
surrounding fluids give a key right
random okay and then this is say is say
D you have then the acceleration and ma
D velocity DT and the force acting on
the Marco or Adam a part of your right
when you start moving you always have a
drag force so the drag force is always
there and drag force is proportional to
velocity
so you're right our into okay
you can write that into normalized to
mass but say it's proportional to
velocity so you can do it back to right
you know for the vector right so there's
always drag force and then you have what
render random kicking force right random
force the fluctuating so that's the
random say driving force here is random
and there's some basically relation
because there's a random force so the
the average is zero itself is zero and
this random force is not related to our
so if you do your time average they are
also zero but the of the driving force
itself of course is related to the
temperature
so if if you say here is say that
different time are at the time s and
this is a it's a the typical given
equation assume this is instantaneous so
there's no memory and here what we have
is to either KBT and delta T now that he
just say instantaneous and this is
random fluctuation is related
temperature and also related to how
large is day is the dissipation here
okay
so this is the linear equation and
solving this is a linear equation
because this is random so actually it
could be pretty you go to rigorous math
way there there are many different ways
to solve this random you can do a
spectral analysis for example
but say in the book I'm not going to
present going through every step and we
have a very non rigorous way just to say
I multiply both sides because this one
do DT do DT can be written as d DT dr/dt
right so if I multiply both sides by r
and you go take the time average in this
term as you drop out so you get a
regular equation you can solve ordinary
differential equations or you can solve
for the radius the division of the
radius of the particle from T equals
zero so here I'm going to give you the
results so if you do the radius of this
R square right this is the day if you
put a partner here after some time where
it's going to be right and this is the
random walk and the radius is 6 K BT M
either and the t minus 1 over either and
plus I have a exponential mass either T
so so this is the solution for the the
distance from the origin due to the
random walk of this particle and you'll
notice there is a this long time this
term drops out right so the diffusion
the distance dip because this is a
related to diffusivity so the distance
will be really diffusivity times the
time square root that's the order of
magnitude of diffusion ins this is a
when you solve the Fourier law of heat
conduction
you know the diffusion is our heat is a
diffusivity times time
square root right so this is a long time
behavior of the Brownian motion so the
heat conduction all this diffusion is a
random walk process and recently there
if you check a literature there actually
a lot of people are doing still doing
the Brownian motion experiment and some
people say with the experiment we say
the initial time the initial term also
and that's the transiting at the start
of the kicking so one interesting
comment I have here is if you look at
the Brownian motion look at the velocity
here right forget about this you see the
velocity will be exponential decay right
because this is the velocity this is
velocity you feel so velocity this is
exponential decay after it's getting
creaking right so and since all this
relation come from related to the
exponential decay that turns out this is
wrong okay and the reason for this is
wrong is in this linear equation there
is also say when your molecule gathered
kick right so the so here we have you
have you use the stocks theorem right
starts track but the one particle starts
from zero right this is a steady state
solution and when a part of your star
from zero stationary you get a kick you
get a transient solution and that
trending term was significant if so if
you add the transient term into here so
there should be a ditional transient
term this starts forth
and that trans interment is integral so
it depends on the previous time
so this equation actually become say
integral equation differential integral
equation and if you solve this in
differential integral equation you don't
get the exponential decay for velocity
you get power law for the velocity so if
you saw velocity is actually if you
solve this transient is T I remember
it's one point five three halves so it's
a very slow decay exponential and power
very different right Spallone sure is
very fast Parsloe so that's the memory
fact out of the boards my equation I
know the other for the linear equation
and that was the interesting this
because so the first study the discovery
of this memory effect right was by
computer so in 1950 or 1960 when people
started doing the computer simulation
molecular simple is molecular dynamics
they find this is not a case of velocity
autocorrelation so it typically you
calculate turns out later on were when
we saw it will go to linear response
theory you see that diffusivity so
diffusivity is related to velocity
autocorrelation so is the T U 0 DT so
that's a velocity autocorrelation
function right so you can see if it's
exponential if it's a power decay you
would expect this is very different
right was the Einstein relation original
relation between diffusivity and
mobility wrong or not right it turns out
that even though
he didn't include even though he has an
exponential decay but the
autocorrelation at the end the result is
same so he was lucky okay they between
the fluctuation dissipation relations
still valid even the decay function is
very different this was later proven
there was a paper later proven
mathematically by solving integral
differential equation see this is still
valid okay so I was interested in this
problem because for Lam peered people
are doing this analysis so they added
nanofluids in the liquid they say
there's a higher thermal conductivity
and their series say their Brownian
motion right whether it's a Brownian
motion in fact and Brownian motion you
do this exponential decay you drop the
verge worth rapidly and you go to say to
all the order magnitudes about five six
automatic too small to actually
contribute to heat conduction then there
are other people and at same time we
actually also found the paper we thought
say that's to say oh this is a much
slower decay okay and because it's a
power law and that may be explaining
they say the the thermal conductivity is
not exponential and they will win the
further and they say okay it turns out
other people prove at least a full
viscosity and diffusivity right that's a
fluid flow problem it's still valid so
then the question is for heat transfer
for energy is that valid or not it's an
unanswered question okay later on we do
the experiment and we don't think it's a
Brownian motion but mathematically
that's a still one thing in my mind is
what today what is the autocorrelation
function for heat and how they decay in
a Brownian say fluids when you consider
this time retardation they map
in fact what people called mamrie in
fact because they it takes time for the
stocks flow to teaching okay so that's
all I'm going to talk about for the bulk
truth right and I think there are
actually really las a very poor
understanding even the basics of
transport in liquid and there there are
some potential to do good research in
this area and the next what we're moving
on is going to talk about the interfaces
and so the what's important is to
understand the potential interaction and
so what are let's look at the forces and
potentials and of course we now force is
the gradient of potential so if I know
the potential I know the force and the
what we're looking at is a more longer
Ridge potential so due to the charge
we're not looking at the covalent force
between that's typically collect the
atoms to form molecules right so when we
look at the longer-range potential due
to charge you can always start the most
basic
so let's do a purse the most basic is a
Coulomb force right Coulomb interaction
will have a positive charge or negative
charge I have this is a q1 this is q2
and the potential is Q 1 Q 2 and 4 PI
epsilon R R is the separation between
the two here is the R ok and you can use
the basic Coulomb potential to construct
all other forces that do to you like to
say this is a charge or region due to
this Coulomb origin here and so for
example I want to understand what's the
potential between say single charge Q
and the dipole dipole is positively
charged very close to each other right
so I'm going to have a dipole here I'm
positive a negative charge and here is
my skill here is plus kill and this is a
say let's say here is a and the distance
of the dipole here is d and the
separation the dipole this D is much
smaller than the radius the separation
between Q and the dipole that's our R is
larger than D right so you could then
just to sum up all those Coulomb
potential
what's my potential here is the
potential is equal to Q let's say to
this kill or to this Q here and this is
a B this is a say
so if I write the 4 pi is long a B so to
the negative charge plus the skill to
positive charge 4 PI epsilon to C a B so
I have a a C so you just write the
distance down and do your math right
using the fact that they so here if I do
the a B for example is our mass D over 2
cosine theta square plus D sine theta D
over 2 square so that's my set the
orientation of this dipole this is the
theta right T so the 1/2 D that's this
distance times sine theta that's this
one and the - that's because on this
side and that's the distance ay B it's
just the hypotenuse of the right
triangle when I'm writing down and
similarly you can write AC and then you
use the fact that R is much larger than
D you ninny ur eyes it and what you have
here I have get a minus ik u beta is a
dipole moment cosine theta and 4 PI
epsilon R square well say beta is the
dipole moon is a Q times D right so now
or this is my potential originally for a
single you can say for two point charge
I have the potential is over 1 over R so
the force is a 1 over R square right now
if I look at the point charge and dipole
the potential is over R square and the
forces
r cubed right because you want to know
what's this relations and as another
example I want to find out what's the
force interaction return to solid
surfaces right why am i interested in
that because I want to say if I put a
particle so your liquid
what's the wonder words of attraction
force whether I can keep this fully to
stable or not right if they grew on to
each other your your you'll have with
the eventual sedimentation how I can
make a stable color you need to know
those four things right so I have
constructed using the simple Coulomb
potential between a por si a point
charge and dipole I can look at the
lecture what I have to say we're going
to look at the dipole dipole so if you
look at two dipoles
due to the Coulomb interaction because
you have the Type O has a say positive
negative issue are has a positive
Ligonier when you interact with the
other one right you got the full term
summation and then you add up all those
full terms and you find out that your
potential for that dipole due to this is
our six right
that's they say when we talk about
wonder worse potential right this is a
the attractive part and they then say
when they get very close
you got a repulsive part here we're
talking about the attractive part okay
and with this you can so this is a two
isolated dipole now with this type or
you can go construct that you if I have
a dipole right and I have a solid what's
the force what's the attraction between
this dipole and the solid the solid self
I'm going to consider nada say a solid
that that's made out for another I say
another singular point charge solid I
see it's a little easy atoms is a
neutral then I can approximate the atom
self as a dipole right so I have say
really each point I have dipole I'm
going to sum up the force interaction of
this dipole with all the dipoles in the
solid so if you do that so here I have
the distance D and let's say here I have
my Coney day X and because the axis
symmetry right so I can consider at the
egg any X I do a say when I integrate
over say infinite right if I consider I
the NEX radio the Russian so this is a
like I have a significant coordinate and
I can write the potential interaction
between this dipole and the ring here is
because say the distance is a six power
so the distance here if I look at this
point and this is the R right here I
have D plus X so I have D plus X
square plus R square + 6 power so this
is my distance and then say I have the
Lambert density of this dipole atoms and
2 pi r dr that's how many I have in this
and then times DX right so that's the
volume and so DX and then I integrate
the x is 0 to infinite this is my origin
0 to infinite that's x r i0 to infinite
that's the a solid right so you do that
what do you get you do your integration
you'll get a day this is a PI C n and
the 60 cubic so D is the separation
between this dipole and the wall and
this solid right and that's a potential
if I do it once I have the potential I
take a derivative so the force is a deep
fourth power
okay now if you go to check in the book
I give an example because if people say
do I have a sleep wanna have a liquid
flow on a solid surface right so I use
this I okay that that represent my own
opinion I said there is no sleep in the
normal condition because I'm just to say
when I have this dipole what's the
bonding force and then I look at let's
say I have the atoms and what's the
potential barrier on the surface and the
question is that whether I have enough
shear force to mobile work those
potential burglars
right so I guess in my point is you can
take that at you whether you you can
criticize it but say the point is you
can develop your
argument and then say you let other
shoot it up and say where is wrong here
right and of course to say USA if you
have very large here you may have it but
it's a practical situation I don't think
there is a sleep between liquid and
solid surface okay so this is a one typo
to a solid and now I can do the same if
I have two pieces of solid right two
parallel plates so we'll have two
parallel plates separated by D and if
both sides are dipoles and again you
integrate now you already integrate one
side you just integrate this other side
also in that case what you have is a Phi
equals months a cow pie d square and
this a is the PI square say and M one
times n to the N 1 to R the number
densities on both sides and this a is
called a hammer curl constant
how many of you have heard of Hamaker
constant right that's where I come from
okay
and so now this is the potential so
what's the force interaction do tend to
parallel plates when the bar is force
that's D Square D cubed right for two
atoms you do these six potential t7
force and for two parallel surfaces is a
sadqa and you can do spheres also
different geometry and the in fact that
you read the books people have done all
this
so what different surface there is a
corresponding that integration give you
different Hamaker constant and by the
way so this was a consider this will
classic or there's nothing really
complicated right you can do that you go
back at you redo it yourself but say
that was a you know I think it was in
1940s or 1950s the same problem would
put a different spin and this was a
suggestion by Max Born to Casimir
Casimir again right so we say Kasner did
this size the effect on thermal
conductivity and I say maximum suggested
to us a cashmere set this one the worst
force that can be understood also as a
zero-point energy
so what I say then Casimir went back
what he did is okay if you have this is
the other way to look at this force and
in this case is no longer electrostatics
here is the electrostatic its Coulomb
force right but see this other way to
understand that is like the mold the
energy of electromagnetic waves stay in
this gap right and so this is an AMOLED
and there are many other modes right of
the if you think about the perfect
flatten surfaces as you move closer and
closer there are more most excluded
excluded so the energy in this cavity is
a smaller right so energy when I use you
know the energy again you take a
derivative of this energy you get a
force and this mode is zero point
because the one half H nu that's the
energy that's a zero point energy in the
cavity and it's the other interpretation
for the one the worst force
so let's now give it a quantum picture
it's a it's important because now if you
look at a lot of work on cars metaphors
and but this one of course is a
electrostatics say this picture is the
natural statics this is the more the
most is the more gain into the dynamics
right so later on there are further
development just to see by live she's
this is London live she's delicious book
and he develop a theory based on just
the electromagnetic wave you calculate
the taxi you really calculate the using
dielectric functions of medium one two
three so what we have here is an
electrostatic minute but if you do
electrodynamics you can have generalized
theory and that generalized theory it
turns out depends on the dielectric
constant leaps onto here we are talking
about one versus attractive this tool
actually if you have another media right
media in butane you can actually have a
repulsive the to surface can actually
get repel each other so some people are
trying to develop that in an MIT chemist
a lot of faculty sarah faculty
Steve Johnson and I think cada mejor
Ankara and several people are working on
this so the idea is that can you develop
a surface there's no friction right
if you can repel those
self-repairing okay
so with this we have talked about the
attractive forces right and like I say
if I want to look at that I put us fluid
Parker in fluids and attractive force if
there are only attractive force they
will agglomerate and the sediment right
and how you you need a repulsive force
to maintain them if you want to have a
equilibrium you can keep this a certain
distance so in the next lecture we're
talking about that but I want to go back
to the solar sea oh I wanna show you few
slides on solar sea oh I didn't have
time last lecture
okay so I didn't call the show any of
this see graphs last time we talked
about PC principal so here is a
shockley-queisser limit calculation for
the maximum efficiency of a solar cell
and depends on the band gap of the
material so here you can say this is say
is a concentration right if there's no
object concentration you get the here
you can say this is about 1.4 that's at
a pig and the pig efficiency is about
twenty three twenty or did that depends
on what kind of spectrum you take right
and originally Shockley say it's about
twenty eight and there this is about 31
32 so this was a paper by Henry so this
is about garden mass tonight and yeah
and one point one is about see this is a
here that's a silicon and so silicon
gotta master either in the good band gap
range and here is the efficiency if you
concentrate the sun's thousand times by
concentration you generate I say more
photons if you look at it then you have
say a larger open circuit voltage and
also higher a short circuit card so you
get a higher efficiency and that's a
single Junction and here was a some
historical and it's an old one you can
say and the silicon the best question is
sitting hung that's this line here and I
actually wizard the Martin Lawrence the
the group two before they say they have
about twenty six percent efficiency and
so it's actually let me say this is
single Junction CO single Junction say
all the best shockley-queisser say you
about thirty thirty one percent right so
that's actually getting pretty close and
what's interesting how here is the multi
Junction CO and multi Junction CO now
it's about the forty one forty two
percent efficiency and forty three
yeah okay
forty-three they split the that's by
wavelength splitting into a different
sales there's another one is the one
okay
and the city I think it here I see this
open this one is the cattle right right
that's the first solar it's a lower
efficiency it's a direct gap solar cell
and the first solar cat internal right
you almost get the worst in the world
but they are most profitable company
because Academy is a is a poison it's
toxic environmentally and you go to
Japan they had an environmental disaster
in the sixty they never touch it caramel
and so but first solar they use this in
film their their film is a few microns
because the optical absorption is good
Dirac gap and they are saline about
eleven percent ten to eleven percent
efficiency right the City Council is
sending about anywhere this is lab
efficient that's the best efficiency
silicon cell is sending anywhere between
fifteen eighteen percent or 20 percent
efficiency so at the end it's a cost
because they are most profitable because
the silicon is about three few years ago
right three dollars show now it's this
car a cost curve is a very dropping very
fast and a lot of work is done on the
polymer solar cell right and that's you
see the history there
and these there is should be I don't
they die sale right this open circle
that's a day die sale and that's about I
should be a bra around the 11 percent
Michael Gretl
and let's say you went early which was
going to win which one goes first
together great party great party means
so you can complete it with the cause
natural gas right that's they it's a
costly very cost since they're
multi-junction cells is trying to use
different spectrum of the witness and
it's actually really quite ingenious in
the sense you have wider gap
semiconductor on top so the red light
doesn't say get absorb go to Alexia and
the bottom let's say you have to collect
them correctly each see I have to
generate because you are now putting the
Syrian series right the top 0 January
senator and current that go to Lexi L so
this the current has to match and also
typically when people come back they do
a quantum tunneling common junction to
collect them so if you make an infinite
junction they practically people down
into three junctions because when you
grew different materials they become
very crabby once the material become
crabby doesn't work recombination too
fast right so but theoretically if you
do infinite Junction you can get around
eighty six percent efficiency that's
today and recombination will already
mentioned so this is a where are the
silicon is very good abundant this is
optical absorption that's not really not
good that's the problem right see that's
the where the cost that you need to
thicker one to get the absorption up and
thats related to matures pure because
you have to use very pure materials
so this is the single crystal and
polycrystalline if you go out you look
at this
that's your say whether you pretend
you're expert whether you have a poly
Krishna look at this colorful that's
Paulie okay that looks like a mole
across my and and then people trying to
do Cynthia
for example amorphous silicon but
Martha's silicon the problem is the
mobility charge do not travel very well
so even though you can use a 500
nanometer amorphous silica it's still
too thick for electrons host okay so you
want to so you want to make it an even
thinner and once you get a very thin the
optical absorption is also problem and
here is the people actually trying to
make say you can see here you have a
mouthful silicon that's it'll by this
band gap and then you have micro
crystalline silicon or you kind of sink
on germanium chain different band gap
and so that you can do multi-junction
cells this is a polymer polymer unlike
the typical PN Junction where you got a
potential in fact that the potential is
not that important just by diffusion
your spy the concentration gradient and
the polymer problem so is a same
molecules molecular chain you excite the
electron hole the problem is the
electron hole they bound to each other
should they actually have a lower energy
that's the exit on and what he wanted is
to extract them out you like Tron go one
side hole go the other side but that
actually tell me if they bond to each
other and you eventually they die they
release keep you do right so is that
first you need to separate the acetone
and then get on to the polymer again
conductivities are not good so people
are doing this three-dimensional right
why is a whole conductor the other is
the electronic conductor that's bulk
Junction solar cells even though it's
when it's a bulk Junction means just a
penetrating junctions P and n type of
materials and they are also you have to
make it very thin and grad saw cell
electric ham Garcia this is a they using
the really molecules say they died as
the synthesizer and its molar layer so
the Cottam Arab nanoparticle is this
Amman on there to increase absorption
again you get the electron hole they
actually tongue and once you get that
because it's a mono layer so general
electron hole and they go one goes to
the solid that's the titanium oxide so
titanium oxide is in cosmetics so it's
pretty cheap and the whole go to the
liquid so the decree that acid is liquid
and diffuse to the electrode so so I'm
they reduced and so so so this is where
because it's a liquid it's not very
reliable and the reliability is a big
problem and so people say this could be
cheap but the so far nobody has been
able to commercialize them okay so
that's where people trying to do okay so
I so here is the first gen silicon base
thin film based whatever sir you can try
to get a lower efficiency say fiery
fishing no cost that's a lot of people
work on this okay stop here and just a
reminder I'll send you an email know you
can win to all your angry
you
you